hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge dass
man sich schon im titel und zwar meine
fans sterben ich habe euch nämlich bei
twitter gefragt ob er mir einfach mal
selbst zu senden wollte ich dann als
kopf für diese autos hier benutzt das
ist beispielsweise einen volleren von
mir ich packe euch mit dem kopf dann
beispielsweise einfach dieses luca mobil
und dann drücke ich einfach mal auf
discount und lasse euch vollkommen in
einem kreisverkehr rasen
ok cool wir probieren es einfach noch
mal mit dem speed cruiser und diesmal
wird es vielleicht eine kollision
aufgeben oder wir es tut mir leid
verloren die scheint es sehr zu
entscheiden ich mal schauen wie sie sich
so auf einem skateboard macht auf jeden
fall recht langsam you can make it is
believing you believe in your dreams
ändern dass das hat jetzt gar nicht
geklappt vor ich euch das nächste
geschichte genauer zeigen muss ich euch
noch eine kleine sache sagen eventuell
könnt euch noch an den videopreis 2015
ändern da war ich in gar keiner
kategorie tatsächlich vorgeschlagen
dieses jahrzehnt ist ultra geil wenn ihr
mich einreichen würde für person of the
year mail
also man kann es ja mal anstreben ich
weiß nicht ich versuche halt irgendwie
youtube in mein leben mit rein zu
integrieren mit vier stunden schlaf und
studium und praktikum noch nebenbei und
ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr das
schätzt und vielleicht einfach mal den
link in der beschreibung trägt und dort
einfach bei einreichen bei ihr könnte
einfach youtube.com strich konkreter als
link angeben und an darunter schreiben
warum ihr das wollte beispielsweise auch
luca redet immer so viel über pizza dass
ich mag pizza und deswegen sollte lukas
gewinnen da könnt ihr auch wenn ihr
wollt einfach irgendein video von mir
einreichen oder meinen instagram account
oder mein twitter account oder halt
meinen youtube-kanal nächstes jahr
komplett egal ich werde nun folgen
person of the year
guckt euch mal übrigens meinen pulli
hier an luca ist dumm weil ich mir
gedacht passt heute vielleicht ganz gut
wird mich auf jeden fall freuen
klickt einfach mal den linken und dann
könnt ihr mich vielleicht einreichen und
vielleicht stehe ich dann auf einer
bühne und las dann den preis fallen weil
ich so blöd bin und
gitter kaputt das wäre doch was das hier
ist das nächste gesicht wirklichen jetzt
einfach mal auch diesmal und und sie
schickt ihren körper und dass sie
tatsächlich
die karte ist komplett auseinander
gesetzt auch mein gott sie fährt immer
noch weiter alter wo fährt der denn hin
die fährt noch ein baum um ich werd
nicht mehr ich habe jetzt mal einfach
nur ein ganz bisschen an führungen geben
um vielleicht zu schauen ob sie dann
jetzt wow den nächsten kopf den wir
jetzt haben ist der hier der tomatensaft
mensch und ich gebe ihnen einfach mal
ein bisschen gas und erfährt jetzt hier
runter und kam dann tatsächlich wenn er
hier mein gott da ist ja eigentlich gar
nichts passiert jetzt lass ihn jetzt
einfach mal mit einem rollstuhl hier die
strecke runter gleiten um zu schauen ob
er jetzt vielleicht von einem auto war
das war wirklich super
gc gut da hinten das hier ist das
nächste gesicht meine damen und herren
er oder sie brettert jetzt einfach mit
voll karacho in den freiraum eine fresse
alter da oh mein gott
fakt ist ich gebe mir jetzt einfach mal
ein feuerwehrfahrzeug falls das
eventuell helfen sorgt
das nennt man dann wohl
massenkarambolage das hier ist die
nächste zuschauerin die familie tod
gestürzt wird und wir geben jetzt
einfach mal versuchen falls dieser
jeweils ich dann folgt aber okay cool
ich gebe jetzt einfach mal so eine
dampfwalze um zu schauen ob damit
vielleicht das kann doch das wird ich
habe gar keinen score einfach das hier
ist das nächste gesicht was wir zu
gesendet wurde uns war es das glaub ich
einen panda mit seiner snap chat maske
gemacht wir lassen sie jetzt einfach mal
hier lang wir haben gar nicht mal falls
wieder erreicht aber sollte trotzdem oh
mein gott sie fährt noch alter dass sie
fährt nicht mehr ich versuche mal voll
spitze raum ein gott full speed um mein
gott das passiert doch das wird doch das
kann doch das ist nicht einfach und die
kann es auf jeden fall kaputt mich
niemals einfach den race länder und habe
auch fast schon wieder fullspeed
erreicht und der
das hier ist auch wieder ein zuschauer
bzw zuschauerin von mir ein gelandetes
elfi blick wir befinden uns ganz weit
oben und geben jetzt einfach mal full
speed mit der limousine hier runter und
das ist das ist doch klar das kann doch
das jedoch das ist doch unglaublich toll
so was brauchen jetzt glaube ich einfach
den kopf weiter der sich dann irgendwie
die in den meisten space raus und kann
und dass vielleicht dann auch alles klar
mit der formel 1 karte macht mir das
alles wirklich am meisten spaß weil die
einfach und schnell auch mein gott mein
okay dass das ist du bist tatsächlich
ein formel-1-wagen bleibt doch stehen
verdammte scheiße drauf gewartet
natürlich kommen auch diesmal der
wrecking ball an einsatz
wieso fährt denn eigentlich jedes
fahrzeug noch weiter wenn ich schon
längst auf dem boden bleibt doch hier
das ist doch die highscore an dieser
stelle würde ich allerdings auch sagen
das war's mit dieser folge tore desmond
es wird für mich noch nach heiden arbeit
sein das kann sie schneiden weil es bei
jedem facebook wechsel dings hier das
ganze neu synchronisieren muss weil
danach immer die aufnahme gestoppt hat
aber freunde dass wir wieder eine vier
stunden schnitt arbeit ich hoffe ihr
respektiert das und habt weiterhin bock
auf sowas und wenn ihr euch denkt dass
das nicht eine person in der
beschreibung ist dieser link führt
videopreis wenn ihr denkt luca hat es
verdient dann erreicht da irgendwas von
mir einigen was witziges aus dem letzten
jahr oder es muss von 2015 sein oder ihr
schreibt ein paar youtube.com schräg
kontrast dahin aber wenn ihr natürlich
denkt dass ich scheiße bin und ein
anderer youtuber das gewonnen gewinnen
sollte dann
steht natürlich im weg aber ich bin
eigentlich also ich eine pizza dem ich
mich